i need you to help me battle covid19
and it's with a step that i'm almost
certain no one has talked to you about
before
this isn't clickbait there's been nearly
200 000 deaths here in the u.s
and over a million across the globe
scientists have largely been stumped
first we say masks then no masks then
airborne not airborne
it's an absolute mess because we simply
don't have info
we don't have data it's a novel virus
but that
ends here because i have you all it
takes is a few minutes
and a smartphone and an app that i'm
gonna need you to download
now i partnered up with harvard school
of public health
specifically dr andrew chan who i'm
gonna be talking with
throughout this video to get you to
download the
covit symptom study app using this app
we can track what this virus is doing
across the united states
we can catch hot pockets not those hot
pockets
we can fight this virus we can find
symptoms
early we can see certain patterns in
fact
it was this very app that first
identified the loss of taste and smell
as a covet 19 symptom i bet you thought
it was me
nah was it was the app as if saving the
world from covet 19
isn't enough i'm gonna sweeten the pot
if you download this app
and it gets to five million downloads
and you comment on this video
you're gonna be entered to win one of
ten brand new iphones we just got to get
it to five
million five million five million
what would it mean to you personally and
also to harvard
if this app gets to five million
downloads rather quickly yeah so getting
our app user base up to 5 million would
be huge
and we hope it doesn't stop there we
want to continue to have people download
the app
because the more people that download
the app the more useful the information
is going to be
how easy is this app to use so this app
is incredibly easy to use it really just
requires
a couple of minutes to download it to
your phone and then answer
a few very simple questions about your
health history
and then provide some information about
how you're feeling once a user inputs
information
what's the things that they get out of
using the app once you share your
information
right away the app returns some
information back about how people around
them are doing
so it gives them for example a
percentage of people that are
potentially having symptoms in their
area
and also gives them some estimates as to
what
covet incidents might be like in their
local areas will the data collected from
this app
be secure is there any threat that it
may be used for nefarious purposes
commercial purposes or is this solely
for research absolutely so we are
committed to
using this data in a secure and private
way
so we have no commercial interests we've
been doing this purely because we want
to drive the science
and to drive you know the ability for us
to collect information and analyze it
and share it back with the community and
share it back with
with scientists you may have heard on my
channel or in the media that
people of color are disproportionately
affected by covid19
but i bet you never heard that doctors
and health professionals of color
are also disproportionately getting
affected by covenanting
usually from the lack of resources where
they work
how do we find that out this app you
also have seen me pooh-pooh
media's coverage of these long-term
health effects of covet 19.
like i last time i referenced this
article that said covet 19 in the brain
why you should be scared i don't like
articles that cause us to panic
unnecessarily this study is looking into
that too in fact it's one of the biggest
surprises that dr chan found when
looking at the data
i think we've been surprised uh uh
along with the rest of the scientific
community that coven 19
is not a often not just a short-term
infection
that there are some people that develop
covid19
and do have some symptoms that linger
beyond you know a week or two but on the
app we've noticed that about 10
of people report that their symptoms
after infection have lingered for as
long as a month
and i think that's been kind of a
surprise because that's not typical
of these sort of respiratory viruses i'm
actually going to run through the
startup of this app and create a new
profile
because obviously i've already been
reporting my symptoms or
the lack thereof it's important to know
you can use this app for yourself
you can also report on others behalf so
if you have a grandparent or a parent
who doesn't know how to use an iphone
doesn't have the time
you can help them out and get more
people reporting i'm going to report
based
on dr mike's dad
okay he's a person over 18 we have adult
consent
create profile okay are you a health
care worker
yes he is 12 seconds later diet and
lifestyle this section is what really
gets me excited
because it really allows us to dig into
the data and see whether or not
things we do on an everyday basis how
they affect
catching the virus fairing with the
virus recovering from the virus
how do you feel physically right now see
this is an important part of the test
because
depending on what you answer here it
will then lead you down a different type
of questioning
but he feels great thank god in just two
minutes it's done and all you have to do
is log in as often as you can
and just let it like even if you're well
you just say i'm doing well cool
it registers that but then if you're
ever sick you log in and say
hey not feeling well here are my
symptoms and the great part is it gives
you
feedback they tell you information right
away that they're learning
real time take a minute each day and
help fight the outbreak in your
community
we have 4 million 164
824 people contributing
that's amazing with economies and
schools reopening we're going to see
upticks in covet 19 cases without a
doubt but how are we to decide when it's
just a small uptick
or a true second wave this app will help
us decide that
if you want to keep your economy and
your schools open participate in this
app
so we don't panic unnecessarily if you
can change
one thing from the us response to covet
19 what would it be
to have really a cohesive national plan
in terms of gathering data
to respond to the pandemic i think we
recognize now how important it is to
know what's happening across the country
and to know what's happening
in real time i really want to thank you
for the opportunity to share this with
your audience and i think
one other point i would make is that one
of the things we've been so impressed by
is that you know your program
and i think your audience really wants
the truth and wants
you know hard facts and information
about covet 19.
if you are willing to share a little bit
information
and involve your your family and friends
uh we'll be able to uh have facts and
have
data that that can really get at the
truth and that's ultimately what we need
to protect ourselves and protect our
community
and respond as a country no matter where
we live what walk of life we come from
you know what our background is i think
we want to hear from you
and this is i think an easy way for us
to let your voice be heard i know i'm
coming off as extremely excited but it's
because i
desperately want you to participate and
download this app we've largely felt
powerless and confused with this virus
because there's so much to learn about
in such a short period of time
and we in the scientific community are
struggling getting research done
you can help us with that all you have
to do is download this app
spend a couple of minutes take a break
from tick tock
i know you like scrolling i know you
like the dancing but this app can
legitimately save lives
and you could win an iphone one of 10
iphones this app gets to 5 million
downloads and your comment is down below
you're officially in the running folks
download the app links below
click here for a doctor pranking video
that's really funny you're going to see
some of my doctors question my sanity
and medical knowledge
or check out this latest memes video
that you may have missed
in fact i'm putting a couple here for
you and as always stay happy and healthy